no one can survive in this world without  help they're too weak to fight you must  be their strength I see my mine  sometimes I wonder if this is the price  for our sins you'll have inherited your  father's responsibilities  I am afraid and they come at a cost this  woman will lead him into a war he cannot  win time has come to choose Joffrey  Renly Robb Stark they're all thieves the  Iron Throne is mine no one wants you for  their king  we are a free and independent Kingdom  power resides where men believe it  resides whatever you need to do it's a  trick you are king a shadow on the wall  and a very small man can cast a very  large shadow  [Music]  if you to answer for your brother's  treason no matter where you sleep  hunt him down this is what ruling is I  understand the way this game is played  nothing matters but our darlings  we'll find you first